like i remember when i first started
dating sydney right i remember we uh
like when we first when we first met and
first started dating i remember early on
because she mentioned this to me to me
the other day i asked her so would you
like out of curiosity what do you
actually think about america right she
was like greatest country in the world
and i i remember
what she did ask no no she was she was
dead she came from like you imagine she
came from like a small town in the
midwest where you know when you first
started yeah when i first started dating
five six years ago right seven years ago
now actually
but it was a long time ago i remember
that was the first time she had
basically like traveled out of america
and she came from a very small town in
the midwest
you know
got raised with the values that you
would expect a small town to get raised
in and
i remember she said oh yeah america is
the greatest country in the world
obviously and i remember apparently she
said i was just like
like that
and she
not her and she and she said uh she said
to me at the time she got like genuinely
offended right
she's she like she she's straight up she
got like genuinely angry at me at the
time for doing that she was like well
jimmy why and then
why why did you make that sound she said
to me i was like so what constitutes the
greatest country yeah and why is america
the greatest country and she was like oh
land of the three isn't it we got
freedom and i mean
i'm like
you know because like i was about to say
i was like if she's about to drop the
freedom bro bomb like i i don't know
what i can say to that no because it's
to me at the time it was just like
living up to the stereotypical patriotic
american yeah because like yeah like
you know america is is a good country
you know but like my my issue is the
more i travel with more i'm just like is
there a greatest country in the world
and there's no way you can define the
greatest country in the world otherwise
everyone will be living there yeah
exactly right and to me patriotism as a
british person is just so weird like you
see it you i see like american
patriotism where um you know not saying
every american like this but like
especially
some of the some of the americans i've
met who have who were raised in small
towns especially when i go when i go
back to sydney's hometown it's just you
you see you see kind of like this
culture and this culture that's been uh
and this idea that's just been
uh propagated through the small town and
there's not not really been any other
perspective to really change that
perspective so by there by by their uh
by their
like they properly believe by their
belief they probably believe that
america is the greatest country in the
world uh
and there is no other thing that can
challenge that and yeah it's it's just
i'd like i can't blame them for that
i'm not even saying america isn't the
greatest country in the world i'm just
saying
that
because their belief has been permeated
so deeply that there's been nothing to
really break that mould for them and it
took years for sydney to really kind of
change her perspective it didn't take
like just one trip to england it took
years for her traveling to uh to you
know living with me in england and
living with me in thailand and living
with me in japan for her to like really
open up her perspective you're like you
know what maybe there are some other
good places in the world as well you
know
you know maybe some other places do
things
as good yeah and um and now she has
recently just gone back to america to
visit her family yeah and she's like wow
i uh i really don't fit here there
anymore really yeah that's uh it felt
weird because she told me that she just
didn't feel like as settled as she used
to be
just because she she had like she feels
like an outsider almost yeah yeah yeah i
definitely got that when i was uh back
in wales last time i don't know it's you
know i i love my hometown and i love my
friends but you definitely feel like
because you've been
doing so many things and exploring so
many different cultures you definitely
feel like god i must sound like that
weird [ __ ] gap student who come back
yeah i've traveled the world now
i'm better than all of you it's it's
because i really don't want to sound
like that yeah i know but you it does it
does open your perspective a lot and you
do think like oh [ __ ] like
it really does make you look at stuff in
your tiny town a lot different
and
you know how homogeneous it is the tiny
town just feels so much more tinier yeah
weirdly and and it's like and you know
again like i don't blame like sydney or
anyone from like the small town to think
that way because again like i feel
especially in america
it really is just like kind of enclosed
when it comes to the information that
you can get about the rest of the world
like it still blows my mind that like
and like in america for example like
24-hour news channels are a thing but
it's not world news it's american news
for 24 hours and i'm like
what
it's just insane to think like this for
one there's so much news happening in
america that you can just constantly run
news stories but also like there's just
so little
access or ease of access to information
outside of america so in the uk though
really we get like we get trickled down
from america we don't really see a lot
of inside america like
you know a lot of british people don't
really know many of the states outside
of the very famous ones oh well i'm sure
it's the same in australia
stuff like that and we have a very
rudimentary knowledge of uh
outside of europe really do you guys
have like world news on your tv yeah but
like world news is just mostly
but it's mostly the middle east conflict
that yeah that we [ __ ] up really
stuff that we had to hand in
it's rare that we hear anything about
japan or asia in general that's like
something massive well because of the
olympics normally yeah yeah yeah because
bbc scarcely reports on
japan like i have the bbc app and i said
like the japan section they don't do
like an article every like three days on
japan all right it would be very it'd
probably be quite high profile stuff in
japan yeah very wacky whoa
they opened up a new store with m m's
but uh also i do think as well the fact
that a lot of people think
one of the reasons why people really
think america is terrible is uh
you know in the uk and also in japan i
feel this as well a lot of this like
bad stuff and injustices if you will in
the uk and i think japan as well
probably don't get as much
spotlight as they do in america and also
everything is [ __ ] filmed in america
sure literally everything is on camera
in america so like i feel like it's way
easier to catch the stuff that makes
your country look [ __ ] insane yeah
yeah when when you know there's cameras
all the [ __ ] time capturing
everything and i feel like the one of
the main reasons why we see so many
insane stuff for america looks good you
hear about all these horrible injustices
that have been done is because there's
just so much video and there's so much
attention brought to it by the media i
mean it's also as well the fact that
like you know just simply the population
difference is one thing as well but it's
also again it's just like that whole
cultural mentality or i guess like group
mentality of like it's me versus the
world you know not so much because like
you know it's very much an
individualistic society where it's like
i'm the center we have the uk as well
i think the uk way more i think it's
definitely like that's definitely one of
the biggest difference between east and
west that i've felt living in both
different places yeah yeah and like you
know whereas in japan it's like oh i
don't want to i don't want to stick out
too much because otherwise the camera
might get stuck on but it's hard right
because on one hand you get you get a
society where you know
everyone's comfortable nobody nobody
oversteps their boundaries but
everyone's [ __ ] miserable so exactly
so it's like you know
you know you can't have the this utopian
ideal japan without also being very
having a depressed society where no one
can have and i feel that's like the
problem right now is that like yeah
regardless of if you're an
individualistic society versus a
collective society there's still [ __ ]
that happens
the stuff i love about the uk is also
i'm near certain the stuff that i love
or is also the reason why we have a lot
of the stuff i don't like about this
yeah yeah exactly uh you know i mean
same thing with japan yeah yeah yeah so
it's you don't you don't get the good
things
there's no there's no perfect country
there's no perfect country and i don't
think there's a place denmark's just
like hello
an article that was like people who live
in denmark that are unhappy are
extremely unhappy because they're
supposed to be the happiest country on
earth right yeah so the people who get
sad there or their life isn't going the
way they want they feel more depressed
because they're supposed to be because
everyone around them is happy yeah it's
supposed to be in the happiest place on
earth
you can't [ __ ] win like no matter
what goes wrong you can't win
but i think obviously if uh you know
that that also depends on you know if
you can afford to be healthy and all
that stuff so that all changes yeah
being healthy is pretty good
are you guys patriotic
ah no
only in like sport
yeah yeah like pretty much the most
patriotic i get is towards sports but
like you have to like okay so i think
well whale's patriotic and being in the
uk is a very different uh
how many times how often do you get to
be patriotic about wales
anytime england [ __ ] up
that's basically right
i'm not
that's what i'm saying it's not uh it's
not
patriotism in wales is not like the rest
of the world patriotism right now go us
it's just [ __ ] england yeah i i feel
like that's just literally just scotland
and irish like uh northern irish yeah
patriotism that's that's why i feel like
uk patriotism is a completely different
brand to other
yeah because because it's you know we
get very proud of welsh people obviously
but we get the most proud when it when
it is to the detriment of england
yeah so you know when people are like oh
you're like english though right it's
like no i'm not even i have no there's
absolutely nothing about me that is
english
i'm i'm british and welsh but not
english yeah yeah so yeah a lot of
people always like that's english right
no no no no i despise but but i only i
despise it in a very fun way you know
yeah it's very much like uh